bonsoir merci d'être avec nous alors on
peut-on parler dans cette affaire de
victoire éclatante pour lula bonsoir
stéphanie alors comme vous l'avez dit
sergio moreau le juge à l'origine de la
première condamnation de lula était
déclarée parcelles par la cour suprême
du brésil
donc oui en effet c'est une nouvelle
victoire judiciaire pour l'ex président
de gauche brésilien qui fait écho à
celle du 8 mars dernier déjà quand le
juge de la cour suprême déclaré que le
tribunal de curitiba dans l'état du
parana n'était en fait pas compétent
pour juger l'ancien président du brésil
concernant quatre affaires présumées de
corruption
il avait donc annulé toutes les
condamnations concernant lula alors
quelles seront les répercussions celle
déclaration de la cour suprême pour le
juge brésilien
je pense que on peut le dire que le juge
sergio moreau est dans une très mauvaise
posture s'était en effet l'homme fort de
la grande enquête anticorruption baptisé
lavage à l'eau et bien cette enquête est
aujourd'hui dans une impasse et une
défaite cuisante pour le juge sergio 8
sergio romero
l' enquête avait déjà été discréditée à
de multiples reprises par les
révélations notamment faite par le site
des intercepts fondée par glenn
greenwald et qui révélait des échanges
de messages montrant une collusion entre
les procureurs et le juge serge moreau
d'ailleurs comme le souligne le
chercheur à l'iris christophe ventura le
juge moreau est sous le coup d'une
procédure lancée à l'initiative des
avocats de lula est considéré recevable
le 9 mars dernier par une commission
d'étude de la cour suprême la
crédibilité et l'impartialité du juge
moreau avait déjà été largement mise en
doute quand il avait accepté fin 2018 on
s'en souvient le poste de ministre de la
justice de jacques ambühl son art au
juste après avoir fait condamner
lula est d'ailleurs en parlant
bolton araud comme le note le
journaliste romain minibus fondateur du
site les deux rives le président de
droite conservateur sort renforcée par
la mise à l'écart du juge serge moreau
qui allait constituer un sérieux rival
pour lui lors de l'élection
présidentielle de l'année prochaine
mais lola est à nouveau dans l'arène
pour cette élection n'est ce pas en
effet c'est un rival de poids et
inattendu pour bolton arrow qui peut
maintenant se présenter
le juge de la cour suprême avait rétabli
dès le 8 mars l'ensemble des droits
politiques de lula
alors même s'il ne s'est pas encore
déclaré l'ancien président socialiste
est à nouveau éligible
et s'il se présente ce sera un bras de
fer en forme de revanche en 2022
car on s'en souvient au moment de la
campagne et la dernière campagne
présidentielle au brésil en 2017 aulas
avait brusquement été évincé à cause de
ses condamnations pour corruption qui
sont aujourd'hui dénoncés pour pour vice
de forme
il était alors pourtant le favori de la
présidentielle mais comme il a été
écarté alors c'est bolton à rocchi avait
pu l'emporter haut la main âgé de 73 ans
en 2018 il avait alors purgé une peine
de 18 mois de prison on s'en souvient ce
sera donc pour lui s'il 0 vient en 2022
une motivation redoublé par les
injustices qu'il estime avoir subi
alors l'au delà et qu il définitivement
blanchis alors alors alors actuels à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui ces condamnations
sont annulés le parquet avait fait appel
de la décision du 8 mars
mais l'appel a été rejeté dès le 12 mars
d'autre part s'il devait être à nouveau
poursuivi pour les mêmes faits les
procès contre lula devrait être prêt à 0
et dans une autre juridiction
ce n'est donc pas totalement réglé pour
lula même si les choses les choses qui
semblent quand même prendre une tournure
à son avantage en effet la décision du
juge de la cour suprême et celle du
tribunal suprême fédéral vont dans le
sens de la défense de lula qui a estimé
depuis le début
le juge moreau avait été avait instruit
la faire à charge contre le président
afin de l'empêcher de briguer un
troisième mandat c'est le fameux lot of
hell qui des noms que dénoncent en
choeur la gauche latino américaine et
qui touche mensuellement lula mais
également l'ex présidente du brésil
dilma rousseff ou alors l'ex président
de l'équateur rafael correa le lof elle
qui est l'instrument talent isation de
la justice à des fins politiques
et d'ailleurs lola n'a cessé de dénoncer
un complot politique contre lui et a
toujours clamé son innocence
mais rennes dernière question dans quel
contexte se trouve aujourd'hui le brésil
à un an de la présidentielle
alors le brésil a été très très durement
touché par la crise sanitaire qui a fait
près de 300000 morts dans ce pays et le
nombre de cas ne cesse d'augmenter ces
derniers jours le pays va donc devoir
affronter les conséquences économiques
et sociales et ce sera tout l'enjeu
de la présidentielle de 2000 22
d'ailleurs lula n'a pas arrêté de
dénoncer le bilan de bolton arrow
pointant des décisions imbéciles et sa
gestion chaotique de la crise due qu'aux
vives 19 nada et ad'ailleurs pardon oui
bien sûr je voulais terminer mejia me
croyez vous aviez terminé je vous en
prie conclu les jeux ce qu'ils mangent
je peux juste vous signaler que lula a
d'ailleurs récemment formulé un appel au
président français emmanuel macron dans
une interview accordée au journal le
monde le 19 mars et dont le chercheur
christophe ventura s'est procuré des
extraits non publié lula il interpelle
emmanuel macron pour qu'ils fassent en
sorte de réunir les grands dirigeants de
ce monde au sujet de la nécessité de
faire du vaccin contre locaux vides 19
un bien commun de l'humanité
merci meriem l'arrivée journaliste pour
le site arte et france point verte et
france 3 tv spécialiste de l'amérique
latine merci à vous